une fois notre objectif n'est pas
d'entrer au top 50
apparemment c'est réussi c'est pas
l'objectif
pourquoi c'est moi ça me dérange pas si
on y rôde puisque c'est pas c'est juste
un critère de vente si on vend beaucoup
d'albums je suis très content mais c'est
s'adapter pour le top
non on n'a pas fait pour vendre beaucoup
d'albums c'est pas pour ça qu'on fait un
disque ouais enfin pas nouveau vous
connaissez jean-luc man et de best n'ont
pas tellement c'est un mec qui te désire
avec vous à memphis et le dernier moment
il n'est pas venu vous êtes au courant
alors il a caractérisé il avait eu ses
langes il le dit dans l'article x à la
rencontre entre les les seventies
franchouillarde a dit il est la plus
unanime it et d'éternels adjoint plus
unanimité d'éternel adjoint qu'est ce
que c'est l'article terre ils pouvaient
sa partie dérive non simplement on nous
a dit ad gentes qui veut venir à memphis
on refuse toute interview quand on
travaille parce que on perd du temps et
je réserve confronter entre un album
donc on refuse aux prix de studio tous
les pas voir avec le bel dans les pactes
des best of et hier c'est pas l'énorme
succès public baptiste voilà ça commence
alors si vous vous réfugiez par un coup
là c'est quoi alors on fait un coup on
fait de la musique les gens le temps
d'écouter de la musique
un album on a mis deux ans à le faire il
ya douze morceaux dessus ça dure voilà
quarante voix le vendus soit la fête
dure 45 minutes les gens tout en fait
pas besoin de novandie va cartonner en
scène louis excuse comme tu as souffert
longtemps d'être un ex higelin izia pas
super comme ça pendant des années les
trois mecs ce téléphone c'est terrible
je souffre tout le temps pour que ces
terribles en ce moment je suis un ex
bertignac et des visiteurs nan sérieux
non jeu ça me fait pas souffrir d'être
un ex que ça dépend ce qu'ils
m'appellent ex c'est ce qui regarde en
arrière moi je m'appelle pas ex vous
n'allez pas y couper je vous parlais de
téléphone vous en doutiez quand même
c'est dû à quoi le split de téléphone
est-ce que ça passe vite et parce que
jean-louis discuter tout avec ravard pis
toi tu avais plus envie de te battre ce
que tu avais pas mieux fait de bonnes
contrôle sur la musique et que cette
échappée
c'est vrai
il y avait des choses qui m'embêtait
dans cette affaire ouais mais c'est ma
faute je mets pas du tout ça sur leur
dos et ma faute c'est que c'était pas
assez bête je me suis désintéressé d'un
méchoui comme ça quand il ya un truc qui
me gêne un peu parfois audio du thé mais
je me dis bon je fais autre chose si
c'était à refaire tu te battrais où tu
ferais pas se préparer on se refait pas
brillé